I'm G fueled up sponsored ladies and
gentlemen get yourself a cheap field
today 20 off with our promo code in the
description box guys we got ourselves a
trailer for The Flash and despite any
earlier controversies that have been
talked about I am looking forward to
this film finally coming out it looks
like it's finally coming here it's gotta
be the greatest film of all time yeah
and like Coy said earlier we are the
cast of Flashpoint right here of this
new Flash movie Ladies and Gentlemen
please go ahead and leave a like that
would mean the world to us if you could
go ahead and do that also uh Coy and
John they finally watched the Justice
League Flashpoint movie right here on
this channel so you guys can go ahead
and check that out at some point and
we're going to cover whatever else comes
out of the Super Bowl we'll be a little
bit selective today so subscribe click
that notification Bell to get notified
when a reaction is up or whatever else
might pique your interest you guys
excited I'm super excited I'm really
excited too people
[Music]
tell me something
you can go anywhere
save your mommy online
Another Universe
fight to save this one it's definitely
Affleck
yeah it's definitely this is the world
where my mom lives
I don't lose her again
oh no Ron Livingston oh Ron Livingston's
the dad now yeah the only product
couldn't do it time has a pattern
great cast that it can't help reliving
interesting people different worlds oh
drawn to each other like
no oh
my face so my face
he's turning his powers back you can
also destroy
[Music]
just kept me happening this is odd I
completely broke the universe
it's enormous
whoa damn
created a world with no meta-humans
and now there's no one to defend us
fascinating
foreign
it back
a future
holy [__] oh they're gonna do this thing
damn dude
high beams
what's the plate Batman what do we do we
try not to die
[Music]
oh [__] wow There She Goes
wow
it's not quark
my name is Kara Barry
what are you doing our kids are gonna
want to see this
[Laughter]
wow oh my yeah
I love the trailer I also feel like I
kind of pieced together the whole film
sure I mean is that not what full
trailers
especially in this universe it seems
what I like about the change from
Flashpoint is you know because when
Barry Allen time travels in that he just
replaces other Barry Allen right whereas
here he's confronting the Barry Allen
before Barry Allen had powers looks like
that Barry Allen did never became the
Flash and then they do the thing they do
in Flashpoint where he gets Powers but
it's not he tries to get the powers yeah
it looks like the thing with the
batarang
like having Flashpoint when he a Batman
tries to get him his powers back it
looks like that's that was the moment
but it's the other Berry in this one
yeah he's getting so there's two flashes
like we saw well I imagine that our I'll
I'll go by saying like 2022 Barry or
what year were we in 2023 well also 2023
Barry is the current you know DC EU one
yeah I think it looked like 2023 Barry
goes back probably loses his powers like
how in the it goes in the comic and then
he's so he's trying to regain so I see
some of the reset of the timeline by
trying to get the 2013 bury that and
instead of breaking out Cal L to rescue
him who's been in prison it's clearly
Cara right and it's taking place so then
they gotta go fight Zod together all the
end because they don't have a Superman
yeah and I guess I don't know exactly
how it ends but I feel like the most of
the movies that's pretty much the rest
of the movie right so the question is is
like will he he's probably going to have
to make that choice whether or not
that's where I'm like conflicted on I
imagine that he will make the choice to
ultimately not save his mom let her live
because he's got to keep some things in
order because imagine some of this is
about maturing yeah and like a
coming-of-age story of sorts and then a
new timeline will be established at the
very end yeah yeah
um but it's still a great truth
I want to see all that play out that I
just said like I want to see all that
play out
um it looks awesome uh but yo guys who
wants to hand up first let's talk about
Keaton I mean it wasn't George Clooney
but you know I'll accept Michael Keaton
and Ben Affleck I mean that was cool
because there's been so much up in the
air about like what if they shot what if
they reshot who's gonna appear and this
was cool because I feel like on the one
hand you'd want Batman to be a surprise
but here I was like cool we got two
flashes we got two Batman we got Zod
like this feels very big and connected
in a way that is probably gonna confuse
some people because of the resetting of
the Snyder verse but also this looks
very much ripped out of that aesthetic
and I love just seeing Michael Keaton
back in the suit obviously seeing the
kind of attitude just getting those
hints of the growth of his character
since the last time we saw him in Batman
Returns and uh it doesn't look goofy at
all no no it never looks really badass
they shot it very bertinely too yeah
sure the first time we see him in the
trailer even and there's like a burton
like where he does that pivot tilt where
he like swoops and I love that it feels
like Batman 3 in those moments and I'm
really wondering how much of that plays
into much Yeti's directing style when
he's directing like will he have Cavill
I mean sorry everyone we only have uh
bat Fleck feel like Snyder shots will he
have Burton feel like those shots and
will it feel like the Multiverse of
directing because yeah this this is
allowing us to meld universes and I
think that's going to help people from
not be too confused as to the Snyder
implosion is because you're bringing in
both Keaton and batflick and therefore
you could shoot it in different ways
multiversely yeah and that'd be really
fun and it looks like they did that
because those couple shots of him on the
on the Bat Bike feel very very Snyder oh
definitely well it looks like in the
beginning of this he's probably working
with the Justice League or just Batman I
imagine like will there be more Justice
League cameos at the beginning
yeah Aquaman will there be Wonder Woman
there in the city whatever fight is
going down where he's on the Bat Bike
and like yeah you got Bruce Wayne and
Ben Affleck warning him at the top like
you probably should in time travel but
he's gonna make that choice anyway
because that's such a Learning lesson
for Barry in the flashpoint storyline
and so I'm really liking this and
honestly it looks very
um the flashpoint storyline is also very
emotional because it's the hardest
Choice the guy has to make he has to
basically choose whether or not he's
going to let his mom live or die yeah
and he's also dealing with the fact that
his dad is in jail and he wants to prove
that his dad is actually Innocent but
the thing that I was that I did not get
from this trailer was
who the main villain is are they just
redoing Zod again like it looks like the
remaking Man of Steel of sorts where
there's no Superman so he's able to do
he's able to advance a little further
with the uh what is that machine called
God damn it whatever the machine is that
he's doing to rebuild Krypton I'm
forgetting the name of it but pal driver
thing yeah yeah cool Destroyer no that's
not cool
I forget it's been a long tension
uh World engine uh so yeah that looks
cool and I like things when you know
Keaton is uh doing cooler things than he
did in any of the Batman movies
because we also acknowledge how good
like just the framing and the CGI and
like the actual movie looks here because
we've heard over and over again like
best thing since dark tonight which is
at this point a like Citizen Kane of
superhero movies like you say Dark
Knight when you want to say Citizen Kane
like it's that thing for superhero
friends right and so I've been very
worried about just like how anything
could live up to that and though we did
see a lot of this movie I'm one very
glad they didn't reveal too many cameos
Beyond like the core seemingly cast like
this could be a lot bigger but it also
uh the actual composition and the style
of shot choices and again the blending
of Multiverse of directors all of that
looks like oh this is why Mushi Eddie
we're hearing is like such a force of
nature director like I've been saying
give muchiati Superman after this
trailer I want it way more because that
there was some Superman shots that gave
me like like with Supergirl in that
moment just just give him Superman yeah
I I love the trailer I love the trailer
Ezra looks great honestly as it looks
very emotive I like the new suit on the
third shot first I was a little worried
and then I got immediately used to it
there were a couple of shots with her to
get her like that very ending shot where
they're the two berries or I'm like uh
doesn't get a little like purple same
room yeah there's a couple of uh like
but that's stuff you can easily fix
that's that's not complicated I mean
it's not easy but it's that's me it's
easy for time
for everything they're doing here that's
something they can fix and it's a bit
probably easier to see past in a full-on
scene where you're just sort of used to
them being together I feel like the
uncanniness of that isn't as formidable
as other things can be I am curious what
the ending of this is gonna be like
though because this is supposed to reset
it so is the rumors going to be true
about whatever the Batman is at the end
of this will it be the one who ends up
being the DCU Batman I still not what a
great way to cast that yeah I mean like
to have that beer Moment Like end of the
movie with because then you've got a
built-in didn't have to see this movie
audience that already is there and then
you've got the we're gonna make an event
in its own way there right and you also
have a way to end uh like I've said a
million times how do you end a shared
universe so what if he sacrifices
himself and stays with his mom like what
if he stays in the floating universe and
then we have the Ezra's die but then I
feel like the DCU would have to continue
on in a way that's dealing with just a
bunch of cataclysmic timeline events the
whole time instead of just allowing
yourself that's exciting instead of just
having like a full-on reset I don't know
we'll see uh I'm glad we don't know
bottom line is I thought it was a great
bottom line is I me personally I thought
it was a great trailer and uh I can't
wait to I really I'm really looking
forward to this and the truth of the
matter is I was I've been excited for
Michael Keaton but he looked more badass
than I expected him I did not know how
I'd feel about the rubber suit coming
back and I want Ben Affleck to meet
Michael Keaton so much more than I
realized until I saw them in a frame and
also watch and read Flashpoint because
it does look different enough that it
won't spoil it but it also might give
you some moments of like oh that's what
they're reference like this looks
different enough you won't be ruined so
check out the comic check out the
Animated Series then watch this you got
time the way how you've always drawn the
analogy of a difference between a
remaking and an adaptation this feels
like a real adaptation that's also do
you know working within the universe of
the DC EU timeline yeah it's an
adaptation versus translation this this
is adapting versus trying to translate a
story and they're using their characters
in a unique way like using Supergirl in
this way and I'm very curious also what
that means per in woman of tomorrow if
that's the thing yeah I don't feel like
it will be that one of course yeah this
this one is a very even even for
Flashpoint serial it's a very specific
type of uh character from because even
just like Superman was I imagine that I
wonder what the thing is where where is
Superman is Superman just dead like were
they come here together that's that's my
question I was like where is super gonna
see him from the chest down yeah he's
out looking for his lost head yeah he's
like the headless horse that's not the
Saga yeah I'm curious I wonder if he's
just like been killed off I mean it
might not exist in that Universe what if
the the Kryptonite or the Kryptonian
that gets sent to Earth is just her and
then you solve that true in that
Multiverse all right guys well what did
you think about the Flash trailer leave
your thoughts down below be sure to
subscribe leave a like
um and hey uh check it get some G fuel
today it's gonna be helping this
individual out for a lot of today fast
is The Flash let's end this with a
Maria Hammond Maria if I had the powers
of the flash the first thing I would do
is speed on over to wherever you live go
visit your family find out what went
wrong with your family and then go all
right I'm gonna time travel back in time
and go fix this to make you a sensation
and on top of that what I would do just
to put a little bit of extra whipped
cream on that ice cream of yours I would
then I like that analogy I'm gonna use
that way more often now get ready for
that to be abused Maria what I would
then do is uh go back and find out what
the winning numbers are for the lottery
and make sure you get that winning
ticket so that way you can succumb to
all sorts of greed and spoiling people
but I hope you put at least a third of
that money into our patreon page and I
know you're good for that
why would I not just do it for myself I
don't know why would I not just use
these powers to do more than help you
gain Financial Goods I don't know but
that's what I would do with it because
right now I'm looking at a box here that
you got me for a wedding present I have
not yet done a video for it you know me
I want to take the proper time to not
rush through something like that but I'm
already knowing that I'm gonna love
whatever the hell's in there and I love
you so thank you for being you Maria
speed on over to you soon
foreign
[Music]